oh well fresh fresh off the old the
miles records bad let's try the my hot
kid is back
do me my city give me my the key to my
city well you know what they enjoy they
wanted add a third show I said can't do
it at that altitude you're smart yeah
whenever they go third show I go let's
do it shout out to all the people that
came out greatest Club greatest crowds
shout out to you to mom and aunt nubby
who came by my my mom came by mom and I
know became by boson it's good sure did
she put he's so smart and so hot she
goes sexy as all get-out that's what she
said not good sexy it's all get out your
mom said that and you see my my bro I
always forget how high her cheekbones
are and how cool how simply beautiful
her face is and as we head am height we
are I'm not afraid of a taller woman as
you know I'm not afraid I'm not see a
lot of guys got into light in the ass
but because I make up for it in the
front you do you know what I'm saying
brother with tail spin in the front yeah
and also I'm a mature man now I'm 51
years OID nice cheese I know how to take
my time with a woman hey bro what did
why I'll be there she was there too
it was just my mom and my hubby nubby
your mom and a lady names too that's my
Aunt Sue you son - oh that's soo - they
were all blond and get all getting more
English they're all still kind of that
so they sure do they're all Brits their
hands off my take it easy bro man can't
dip his toe in the waters of sin no come
on bro
no man did you see the Li at all there I
didn't I didn't you could use a cross we
at the Paramount right yeah but a lot of
people were like Chris who you know
there are a lot of people are like yeah
bet you're proud they're chanting down
with Chris yeah they were down with
CryEngine with Brian's denim with we saw
Chris and Brian's better we saw Chris
and Brian's better question should quit
I'll quit I'm gonna write a song for us
I'm gonna write we both need a life song
and I'm gonna write a theme song for us
you know what I mean like Brendan Schaub
was in the UFC
tall and strong as you can see
I end up him made him from scratch
breathe life into his clay no he's a
little gay you know what I brought
figure a man I don't know I don't like
that too much
I don't know I'm spitballing ideas
okay well nothing wrong but me okay
wrong no no let me see one sweet you
know whatever I will figure it out oh
here we go
yeah I got one that will let me think
no I'm not okay Shawn be respectful
Brian it's 7:00 listeners then big girl
came along saved his life saved his
career now I was doing just fine and in
fact about to give out cuz he does all
the work all day it's not rhyming the
songs not rhyming bro so I don't know if
that I don't know if I like it
do you know what I'm saying ah yeah get
on your knees and thank me every single
day this little birds trying to fly you
will never you just yeah that's right
well I made you from scratch you're like
a chicken that's about to hatch you
don't have wings until I say you are you
know now I'm soon then I'm dropping sort
of souls know that I can shoot you out
of the sky when a time I won't any time
I won't
I don't like don't you forget that guy I
don't like this song okay but I'm just
saying I don't like I'll write it did
you see shark eyes dolls model to Jake
sure did I saw by the way saw shark I
saw a big clop who's lost 40 pounds yeah
unless I was like 40 I go Europe you're
skinny now skinny is his first round
traffic's right he couldn't be one
shoulder
I hope he's listening to this one of you
a little lopsided from football yeah
yeah it's like this yup this guy's
clavicle is call it like the tip of it
yeah it's completely off it tore off
that's from football push it down like a
crane Wow
well gross and gross
hey Club do you have a special tailor
cuz suits don't work doesn't yeah can I
get can I get a suit I need the one
shoulder to be super long the other one
to be a lot shorter on Frank consistent
Frankenstein so man yeah just get up get
up get a mannequin that and just turn it
to its left and then you know Taylor
yeah meanwhile it looks good though 40
pounds lighter I was like clop you look
a little
what you've been doing stop lifting stop
drinking oh these girls pregnant hasn't
drunk for months he's one of those guys
hello peers non-stop in solidarity with
his girl you know yeah when he drinks
beer
it goes to his chest and and his a glass
you know so his ass in this chat just
makes bigger becomes ma he's the biggest
arms I've ever seen it becomes months
I'm 21 I thought you know Chloe used to
joke about that maybe his word collapse
really are they really [ __ ] huge yeah
it's well his legs
asked and then that small waist that
that tsunamis into this giant rippled
back and he I mean I know he's never
seen it's like oh dude are you are you
eating just sweet potatoes romaine
lettuce and dry chicken oh they'll write
what I want what I'll go to Burger King
whenever I want afterwards I'll eat all
the sweets yeah I'll eat all the ice
cream stay shredded while you guys kill
yourself dieting it's crazy I said to
him I go are you to change a diet
because now I eat like [ __ ] still yeah I
just never drinking I know damn it he's
a such a freak man genetics just such a
freak Jenna smart dude killing it now in
real estate I did a video for Brennan
and I was like you know me and clop and
J and all his boys you know and Cody
Cody Cody Donovan my one of my favorite
people
you're welcome shout-out to high off
dude martial arts where I stay out of my
gym bro I train with my boyfriend Chris
now they give you a white belt shirt
right gave me a white belt and by the
way train with Christian Allen I'm not
trying to be a dick but in a lot of ways
if you step up to me I don't give a [ __ ]
who you are I got some tricks up my
sleeve yet the Christian tricks
pack a lunch well many times I'm a
Christian who trains Neil Magny
all the guys there it was Curtis maids
Curtis blades it was Nate marquart's my
trainer Cody Donovan's Elliott Marshalls
it's an artist once an artist I learned
everything from that Bay Area writing
everything my entire my entire style was
mimicked after Christian Allen who's a
hunter not afraid of
yeah not afraid to not afraid to
tiger-stripe his hair and not afraid to
wear a pair of camouflage overalls that
are also knickers that stop right below
the knee and and some laceless red
dopest [ __ ] sneakers and then sort of a
floral pattern not
like your shirt florals in right now you
there is it you would look at him and go
well he's a twink I look like a giant
now yep he's a gay twink that's what
you'd think to yourself and he'll change
your heel chin go ahead and fight him
see what happens I don't care if you're
a professional football player you're
going to sleep
Christian uses his rounds he'd stay in
there and he'd spar cuz use shankaram
and eyes
coach remain coach we say it's a sports
bar with he'd stay in the ring mean
Shana rotated anonyme beat the [ __ ] out
of both of us we couldn't touch him it
was exhaust it's so crazy he's such an
artist such a unique he's just won like
the job striking he's a John dollar
strike that's exactly right but he's
also black button on the ground
phenomenal black belt jiu-jitsu
phenomenal wrestling phenomenal striking
phenomenal kicking he just does it all
it does it all fighting his language he
had fun there I loved it I thought was
my boy Cody doing Cody's great Cody's
the coach and loving it right in his
element I said to him I go he's such a
good dog he's always thinking about how
to improve and subdued it for a second
just know that you're doing everything
right your worry is gonna lead you in
the right direction this is all good but
you're you you you know you've done
you're doing some good [ __ ] he's got a
good team and it is they have a really
good team and did he go God willing if
Jesus wants that we'll figure we didn't
have any of that talk we didn't have any
I'd talk but but he's gotten more
religious has gotten older which if
that's your thing religious I haven't
picked up on that he's a searcher so
Cody Cody may be religious but he loves
talking no he's very very smart
oh there's one of the smartest people I
know yes and super creative
yes super super creative yes there's no
doubt know y'all know all that I'll do
drawings you see that's Cody
yeah I'm delete he draws a soft really
yeah very smart guy yeah really good
coach yep yep it's a it was a it was a
good it was a good scene and you have
mastered striking and that's the motto
that's the mighty master striking punch
in the face you know
well don't hum that with my face don't
think your chat about there on me that's
all I'm gonna say no you're not I'm
saying brother that ball don't call me
brother did you watch the fade or fight
and criticize them I have some notes for
fade art I knew it
okay I got some notes for fade or that's
all you will you missed a hell of a
fight companion
Eddie at the very end brought up how do
we know nuclear bombs or actual nuclear
bombs
oh we know their job just trying to
control society saying we have new
splitting the atom is not is not real
than Hiroshima and Nagasaki it's a lie
that's why I brought up Hiroshima
however here's a point as far as the
common person to the naked eye if you if
I if you shot watched a video of a
hundred bombs yeah and no one told you
what's nuclear watch regular bomb the
common person can't go oh that's nuclear
hope that's regular TNT that you know
you wouldn't know we just he's saying we
assume and I'm on your son we assume
though just because the media goes well
that's a nuclear bomb because it has
that cloud we go okay then that's the
nuclear bomb Korea has nuclear bombs
Russia has nuclear bombs he's saying we
don't know for sure we assume these
things because they tell us that's a
nuclear bomb then I get the split atoms
all that with any and all these guys and
I love it did you hear it Jamie let hard
Adam yeah Jim got a in physics oh really
Jane whatsupelle you go back to n Rico
Fermi you go back to the history of the
splitting of the atom this was not mine
Stein the problem with these guys is
they're not students we mean these guys
they're these conspiracy guys like
they're not students of history so it'd
be a lot like this for real and I'm not
exaggerating it would be like me walking
into Eddie's school or someone's school
and saying guys this jujitsu stuff
doesn't work it's [ __ ] do you know
that there are kung fu systems out there
where the guy can not only walk on water
but touch you and you will die and I
have six movies to show you on YouTube
and I'm going to show you these examples
and now I have that I want to show you
some video of these Aikido masters who
aren't even touching their students and
throwing them that's on YouTube and
that's true dude
yep so there are Kido masters that even
though judges have been around for
forever oh well yeah and when it's been
used in the UFC constantly it's a little
bit like saying looking at your phone
your cell phone are going this is magic
this is all [ __ ] erisa yeah well you
and you would be but there's a there is
a measurable systematic
reason why it's working this is why it's
working and you'd have to go all the way
back a hundred years or even more to
analysis of how electromagnetic fields
were created with different metals with
nickel and copper and an ax and a medium
right so you give you if you study the
history of science ought to be a deep
but I've done that a little bit of
course not
you go so is Jamie there's there's a
[ __ ] historical record that is
worldwide it's not not controlled by the
Illuminati the only reasonably I don't
get upset already says I like when he
iLike people who question things I'll
see I don't go balls deep in those guys
science his questioning things but sigh
no but and then they then they diffic I
know I know the only thing is when he
goes how do we know that's an actual
nuclear bomb that's going off in the
ocean
how do that's not regular Bob we don't
know they say it is how do we know it's
new and I don't know yeah but they but
the military someone be someone who's
educated knows nuclear testing was such
a problem what he's saying he's saying
if they go oh they're nuclear test over
there it shows a picture of that bomb
exploding we all go
yep that's a nuke when he's going is it
can we get someone to tell us exactly
why it is that's what he said that's
fine he was making a really simple face
value point are you with what do you do
people are blown out of proportion like
no no we know cuz of the thing what I
like about Eddie I tried the rail and
maybe I tried doing and I went I was
super awkward how about the Cavs Jamie
and then it just it was they got heated
what I like about Eddie is that he he
has a healthy American skepticism of the
government which is I don't trust the
government I don't mind that I don't but
but also like anybody I don't mean to
pick up the way Eddie views the world is
what gave Eddie the ability to come up
with a jitsu system that's never been
around a very creative artist well he
looked at things and goes he looks at it
completely different than the rest of us
and that enabled him to create this
wonderful life with jujitsu
this system tooth where he was like the
rest of us or not not us would like the
rest of everyone doesn't question
anything you don't get tempted you I
would even argue that Eddie because he's
such a creative mind and artistic I
would argue that a lot of the conspiracy
theories that Eddie likes to embrace he
does because it's fun like it's fun for
him too
to be part of this community it's fun to
question these things it's fun to kind
of find these holes a lot of is just
almost an you know if you really held
his feet to the fire I think he'd be a
lot more reasonable I think he just
enjoys he's going down the rabbit hole a
lot of people I meet say I'm Tribble you
travel around doing conspiracy theory
shows you know that's awesome awesome I
love both those get to it do it love
both those guess um well well I told you
I was reading that book last night I
thought you find interesting I love it
you're reading that but uh charging my
phone for you name is about stealing
their artist the title sounds I go so
you're basically stealing people's work
now what's saying is like how do you
there it is steal like an artist journal
and it's a short book it's not a hard
read at all it's for kids for dad for
reading it but it just shows how like
everyone's influenced from someone else
so the the kind of the example they gave
is it's a New York Times best they're
stealing like an artist and so what they
do is it shows like you know Johnny
Carson was it was grew up idolizing this
guy so his goal was to be just like him
well what happens is you try that style
and then you find your own after time
and you become Johnny Carson well Johnny
Carson influenced David Letterman David
Letterman want to be like Johnny Carson
but he gets a certain point go holy [ __ ]
I'm not Johnny Carson I'm David
Letterman oh your teeth show I'm gonna
do it this stuff kill your guru you
learned from them and then you create
your own style
you don't take their material that's
what I'm saying you come up and you get
their style income and another example
is Conan O'Brien love David Letterman
conan o'brien inspired one to be like
David Letterman and he got to his style
and then it branches off from there Kobe
Bryant says it best he goes the Romanian
come of all these movie isn't I'm trying
to copy what the guys did before me and
I realized there's some things I can't
do cuz of size or whatever it is so I
made it my own but it's just me mimic
and trying to my best abilities to
convey what they're doing but it's my
flavor which is why when you try to be
original study how it's done first
at the base and the fundamentals first I
was the point in this book they're
saying so you know I'm obsessed with
time so yesterday I probably watched
eight comedy specials and watch all this
YouTube stuff read this book so what
they're saying is so let's say you like
Jerry Seinfeld right well who inspired
Jerry Seinfeld that's gonna explain all
about Jeff on Seinfeld well who inspired
let's say George Carlton if he's a Carl
Carl let's say who inspired here calling
George George Carlin who inspired him
then he go to that yeah it was right in
the it's a tree go through this family
tree and you figure out all your heroes
had a hero all your heroes had their
heroes Robert De Niro was obsessed with
Robert Duvall it just goes on and on and
Duvall and for that matter denier also
or where Marlon Brando was the guy so
everybody had a hero and do you know the
expression what I have done I have done
because I stood on the shoulders of
giants do you know who said that that's
a loose translation okay it's an
important thing so Isaac Newton who came
up with the theory of gravity the
theories of motion invented something
called calculus Isaac Newton considered
the father of modern physics the the
Isaac Newton considered his theories on
light and everything else Isaac Newton
is if you ask all the sciences and they
did a huge poll of all the greatest
scientists they said who's the greatest
scientist the greatest mind of all time
well all of them pretty much said Isaac
Newton Isaac Newton was was the
scientist that was the father in many
ways of the Enlightenment the father of
the beginning of the Scientific
Revolution where you would measure
things where observation and proving it
with mathematics and with
experimentation where you could
replicate an experiment so when you say
well this cures this does it let's see
if we can replicate the experiment but
he got it from but more importantly the
planets move like this do they yes let
me prove it and here's how I can do it
and Halley's Comet is gonna is gonna
come over at this time can you imagine
can you imagine predicting when a comet
now Haley did that be using
some some of Newtonian physics but can
you imagine saying that a comet Brandon
in three days is gonna shoot across the
sky don't do it and I did it ten
thousand years ago and it's gonna do it
in another five hundred years and you go
shut up and he goes well I'm using
Newtonian physics and math and this is
incredible
okay and that's what happened and when
Haley's comets shot across and then they
were able to any predicted it would
happen again and sure enough and when
was the last time he is coming in the
80's 90's nineties IRA is a kid yes a
big guess what my rabbi Halley back then
and sure nothing on the day well on the
day Brennan on the day Schumann shoots
across what was it chin 1985 to 1986 day
goes you know what's weird as I I was
gone I was three day and I remember
being a big deal but what's an even
bigger deal was one of the great
scientific revolutions because we were
able to use math Thank you Thank You
Isaac Newton and the people apt after
him and Albert Einstein and before to to
not only and by the way when these
flat-earthers
telling the shut the [ __ ] off because we
were able to produce like essentially
predict when a comet was shooting over
and thereby tell you exactly how the
planets move using math I'm not saying
the subject when I said born I'll talk
about calculus if you're not a numbers
guy yeah ever since to cast I remember I
know I remember in calculus when math
isn't your thing when you weren't
interested in high school or college
dude I want to pull my teeth I faked an
illness I told I pretended to faint in
the nurse's office so I didn't have
thought I really I was like I I'm faint
dude Klopp was good at math I was good
at art I've told story I had clop take
my test for me he went in forged
I couldn't pretended he was me while I
finish our project yeah so I got a
c-minus so Isaac Newton Isaac Newton who
was the greatest scientist even in his
day and was was given a chair I think at
the Oxford or Cambridge and he said what
I have done I have done only because I
stood on the shoulders of giants and
then he had another metaphor which is
I'm like a child skipping rocks across a
sea of knowledge I'm only I'm
brushing the sir yeah with my rocks like
this the gray sizes so again even he has
heroes even he what's interesting I
think of never it does without Euclidean
geometry without you know I'm Pythagoras
all of these great mathematicians mean
us before me yeah but I didn't really
think of it like that it when I read the
TAS own recommend to him like steal like
an artist Jesus Christ you wanna be
original man that's exactly what this is
about
everyone's inspired by somewhere it's
music whatever it is athletes everyone
and then eventually you're not them and
you become this other different sort of
branch music especially influenced by
music especially yeah colleagues didn't
I tell you I knew you had comedy
annually I knew you'd be a comic
executed because I watched how you cuz
you had never really been around you've
been around athletes a lot and and great
people but you've never really been
around a lot of comics actors artists
you hadn't been around a New York flavor
necessarily and so you got around me and
you got around some of the old we were
all older than you and what I noticed
was that you were able to watch the way
we were we communicated and you would
get the music in your head and then you
would tell stories and make it your own
and I was like this [ __ ] doing
exactly what I did with Jimmy Burke
Jerry McFadden all those guys I met in
New York cuz I remember I was a
foreigner so I come to New York where my
mother's from we were older they were
New Yorkers and I was like the way they
would talk you know when I use
expressions like he's not hearing a
[ __ ] peep out of you that's Jimmy
Burke but you guys also use Bubba
Jimmy's I talk Jim I only refer on my
stars Bubba
that's Jimmy Jimmy Rock so weird yeah
they say accents that's that's why I
like the English accent someone heard
one do talk like that like alright and
then they started mimicking that and
then you have this whole heist goal that
from get out your bubble Ebonics like so
ghetto like I be he be you know it's
tough yeah like like from 17th century
England yes not that's not that's not
even an African thing that is a British
that was British North British high like
a slang the way people talked and then
because when the slaves were brought
over to the South the people that
settled the South were primarily from
that
of England correct that's where pit bull
fighting came in all of that English
like culture 17th century culture was
absorbed by the black population so a
lot of the language and Thomas soul is a
black scholar does an amazing job of
drawing that lineage we are all products
and you know I was trying to write this
joke it's a little offensive but when
you see cultures that had no contact
with other cultures when you see
cultures that have never been so they
don't they haven't learned from other
cultures so the Yellow River the Yangtze
and China that the reason so many people
speak Mandarin is because they were able
to train along those rivers yeah and
they shared ideas they shared ideas on
architecture on agriculture and medicine
and all that so that's why China became
a great society Europe was the same
thing they were always constantly
together
Japan Japan not really though right well
Japan was very very isolated you ain't
got a lot of what they got they don't in
a minute they got a lot of from China
Japan Japan for us and Japan's not as
multi-culture as the other societies
right so what what what destroyed Japan
why did Japan
why did Japan essentially initially why
did the samurai go out of fashion why
did the samurai lose there's a value
didn't have gunpowder they didn't they
didn't have come power they didn't know
how to use gunpowder in Europe had been
trading and sharing ideas the
Enlightenment the [ __ ] Enlightenment
which gave rise to the Scientific
Revolution gave rise to the distant of
them you know the committee almost the
internal-combustion is in physics and
all the things we the technology we use
that was a results the fact that we were
in contact with so many different
cultures
why was Western Europe why did Western
Europe develop faster and a lot of ways
and become wealthier than Eastern Europe
well part it was because Eastern Europe
though that Western Europe had the Gulf
Stream what's the Gulf Stream it keeps
things warmer so so rivers flowed
throughout winter and led to the sea in
Eastern Europe those rivers froze up so
the [ __ ] stopped you didn't trade and
you can really you can really kind of
reason why yes man you can see it all
the autumn steel and coal deposits they
were in Western Europe so they had more
access to fuel and to Frank and Steve I
was watching Bill Maher's
Bill Maher show and they had a guy on
there they're talking about how diverse
how like the United States is a melting
pot and the
voters on Trump and the statistics are
so interesting and they're saying
because he oh stop saying everything's
I'm melting like you you as well such a
melting pot like the entire world is
there's very few nations that aren't a
melting pot we're not different
nationalities different direct
ethnicities that he goes the only one
that's really not is Japan that's right
and it makes us the one that's kind of
which when you borrow from cultures have
you ever seen cultures that are really
isolated you ever see the original
cultures and you go in and then they
usually you'll see them they're in these
costumes and they're dancing and to
someone instrument and you're like oh
those are ridiculous hats suck the women
are fur women are making bread from
scratch and binding their feet in their
mouths shut
that's right you're like that we become
more modern when we when we learn from
others look at look at the greatest
example in my opinion is mixed martial
arts think about karate in Japan what do
you remember IRA I'm old enough to
remember because I fought them shotokan
karate where you would only learn purely
what your teacher taught you your
Japanese teacher dude your phone we
would fight them cuz my teacher was a
boxer and a judo guy when we would fight
them in tournaments they would stand
still I thought this this guy was like
this the best Shotokan he would stand
there and stand up and they would do
they do this point I would [ __ ] it would
run circles are you [ __ ] kick him in
the same idea yeah you did I'm gonna
shout fake here move this way and I was
who I might but the point is you have
any influences you're like you're liking
those Flintstone you know goddamn
testicles yeah that hilarious story you
tell about [ __ ] you got to bring that
back I don't know if you're still doing
it
awesome the first time you met your
Taekwondo teacher sensei Ted
oh no Zak so funny since a Zak that's a
great bit but but like it's true like
before that with martial arts they were
all different schools Aikido
all right kung fu Taekwondo we're the
best
my master actually it's illegal if he
touches you you die oh yeah then along
comes UFC and now look at MMA now even
we believed it duh yeah but now you as a
fighter go yeah that's good yeah yeah
your Rodriguez incredible fighter but
you go it's not gonna work against the
guys that have been around because the
guys that have been around have they
know how to adjust because they have a
repertoire
Frankie Edgar he's gonna grab you by the
leg it's the same thing with could be
like when people go well if he fights
this guy who's a called wrestler a nice
champion wrestler freestyle when they
wrestle isn't gonna negate I go well no
because this is where with khabib let's
say the double leg the single leg
doesn't work he has seven to ten other
moves in his repertoire that he can go
through the rolodex where and he scenic
he's been wrestling sues for with
grizzly bridge so this doesn't work out
this this don't worry about this of this
where most guys go I have this this this
and then after that we're kind of [ __ ]
if I can't take down Habib doesn't have
that it will never his rolodex will
never expire now extrapolate that that's
a fascinating example because chain
wraps you can you should do that
mentally you should be reading all
different things and I see this all time
with it with academics I see the [ __ ] an
academic is very very specific about his
area of study he's a black belt in his
in his area then he'll do an experiment
and say here's the here's the study
we've done and all of us go all the
cording to that study only black black
Mercedes don't stop at stop signs as
often and they go beyond some with
you're rich you lose empathy true in
some cases and dr. Keller and people
like that come up with these ideas but
you have to be very careful about
drawing large conclusions based on one
study one idea so read a lot read
broadly and widely to get it's exactly
like and and it's exactly like being a
fighter be a thinker be a broad thinker
and we just don't have one brush exactly
yeah exactly
when we all knit Lena that that's what
that's what I love about [ __ ] do that
[ __ ] I did a pot I'm sorry to interrupt
but I love no reading about this stuff
oh yeah because this is gonna make you
know by the way everybody just so you
know I guess would another thing I got I
love about you Brennan was hanging out
with me and my older friends and Brennan
about five years ago goes I don't
[ __ ] know anything these guys are
talking about politics and philosophy
yeah and he was quiet and guess what he
did he just started reading and watching
documentaries and attacking the problem
and now he has his PhD in bro science in
bro simple design Fox now I throw in
just a curveball that's right no don't
kill people know what he's asked rouse
man hey can I give it up
Trump for a second I've been the most
vocal critic of him I was like he sucks
I didn't like him at all
hey you know what and you have to admit
the times when you were a little bit
wrong this [ __ ] is doing
something right because if you think
Korea is talking because they just
decided to talk you're out of your mind
and the media should give Donald Trump
credit I got problems on this person but
this guy's crazy and smart like a fox
because you better get that guy credit
for the first time in seven decades the
two criminals talking and they're
talking about demonization you know why
because Kim Jong Jong is terrified of
that large orange man who talks from
doesn't back down he doesn't back down
because everyone else everyone else is
like oh we do be careful on him play it
cool man don't push the button jump wet
[ __ ] you yeah you push that button you
will see more [ __ ] bombs that will
ruin your country than you've ever seen
before
he was matter of fact I did he pushed up
[ __ ] and he's so know and he sent Rex
Tillerson his Secretary of State over
there he's over there and he goes a
twist don't waste your time Rex and I I
was like this guy's crazy Trump's
[ __ ] nuts if we had to Obama in there
he'd been negotiating I was he's a
critic of him he's a girl I was the one
who said he's out of his mind and you
know what I was wrong and he was right
you know what Rogen later doing
something right made a great point and
it was such a good point when he said I
wake god wide and I think about what I'm
sure people have thought about this for
politics is exactly my forte you all
know this you listening this show but he
goes yeah he was how weird is it that he
and Rhoden goes you know I'm not the
biggest Donald Trump fan I didn't vote
for him I think he said that because
I've never been his biggest advocate
goes but I'm rooting for the guy because
we it doesn't matter he's the president
right here so what if he does good the
economy does good what's good for him is
good for us so just because he's there
and maybe you didn't vote for maybe you
don't like him but we need to root for
him to do a good job because it affects
the way we live so no matter what Jesus
a quit right but who grab the [ __ ] all
that stuff that's what that all right
that sucks man as a person you might
hate him sure but as a president and is
the choices that he makes yeah we need
to quit hating on him and we need to
support cuz no matter what
hate him dislike him think he's racist
think he grabs girls by the [ __ ] hooks
up with strippers prostitue you really
want to spend all that time I was
drawing me Daniels and distract them
from doing you don't what exactly what
you don't want to do is wished ill on
the bleeder of your nation now that but
why are we spending so much time do you
really give a [ __ ] to they had sex with
stormy Daniels does anybody is that
important for the economy when he's
trying to work on the economy more jobs
we're at full employment will give
anyone they know job did it no it
distracts from really she got his dick
sucked [ __ ] you we're at full employment
african-americans apparently are
employed higher there the employment
rate for african-americans by a lot of
stats I'm sure I'll get heat for this is
up the so the economy is doing way
better than people predicted the Koreas
are talking to each other he's appointed
a number of constitutional judges that
interpret the Constitution direct he's a
lot of regulations have been taken away
there's good and bad to that but he's
gotten a lot done that you gotta give
the man that credit he has gotten a lot
I'm not saying you and I get what people
call a raise the biggest critic yeah you
have it I'm giving it up I gotta give it
up to him first prepping I get why
people hate him for racism or whatever
being a fascist or sexist what I get all
that I'm just saying him wrote made such
a great point he's okay as the president
we got to get on board because he's the
leader of the nation and yep don't like
funny not waste our time with this first
of all as the Russian probe come up with
anything after all that talk has it come
up with [ __ ] even Hillary's temps that
kind of [ __ ] up the whole thing cuz
they all the tension went to that
instead of you know really screw things
and and and stormy Daniels and your
speed your the FBI is going into his
lawyer's office talk about an overreach
the [ __ ] are you guys doing should we
get stormy Daniels views on youporn
would I look at them maybe well I
haven't but I'm going to you gotta check
it out going to but I residence I don't
in 2006 he had sexist I don't give a
[ __ ] if a flying like can we stop with
this yes ah very strange anyway that we
just [ __ ] solve that problem from
time don't be stirred up a for president
I'm impressed with Jacques gallon shark
Ellen we can't run they be snooping
yeah stormy Daniels Wow
we make her look like [ __ ] my vodka
Trump yeah did you see I'm sure it's
when you're kinda the Michelle wolf
correspondents thing oh you know you
didn't see the Michelle wolf thing
no what apps you want bad luck inside
room cheese went bad I Sarah Huckabee Oh
walking about that course - did you
watch no I watch it yeah it was mean it
was really good I was I people didn't
give me [ __ ] was like me tweet I went
was funny
let's see it I thought it was really
funny she said something about the
handmaidens she looks like the leader
maids she went hard out and she's right
there this is the thing with this though
again I'm not anti Trump I'm not prom
dress I'm mostly guy living in America
man doing the best I can whatever he
does go up to nothing and do about it
however with Michelle wolf she's a she's
a beast of a comic right she's a
showgirl on Netflix just had a huge
special on HBO which she killed it you
gotta know who you're bringing in you
got to know yeah you got to know what's
going on when you bring her in Chi Minh
goes hey how's everyone doing should
have done your research and then just
goes good and this is what I appreciate
the roasting and all the Paul political
stuff whatever the balls it takes for
her to get up there at that dinner and
destroy it with that what everyone's
walking on eggshells like hopes you
don't bring up and does she bring it up
she brings up and [ __ ] plows through
it and you're just like I'm sitting like
oh yeah oh and it's funny I thought it
was funny [ __ ] man
would you believe or not it was common
[ __ ] commenting it was comedy that I
thought it was really really roast I was
it was a roast it was well done it was
stuff that you knew she was gonna tack
but she did it creatively I didn't say I
respect her I will say this I respect
her for it do I agree with everything no
but it's fun I have to it was good it's
comedy I'll watch it she wasn't a lot
hard in the paint
however this is it no as part of it yeah
I'll say this before you hear this chin
when when you go after Trump like like
some of these comics have done before
and if you look at the track records the
[ __ ] your career up really put you Derek
America well oh they'll turn of the
Trump supporters will attack Oh
that's Amy Schumer well you know Sarah's
a mother she's a mother and I and a wife
and sometimes we get really maybe
yourself
really yikes anyway I mean you if you
have to trump that hard listen you can
be funny about it affair about your I'm
here NASA yeah and the Trump spores go
attention over here in Trump goes get
them Americans are game over Arkansas
has it it yeah game over
yeah so you got you you because you know
why it borders on unpatriotic sometimes
to some Americans they're like I don't
know man you're [ __ ] being you don't
have all the facts and you're also
attacking them you know let me yeah I
watched all that I thought it I thought
it was smart I thought is well done the
ball I look at it and I go got the balls
this woman has to do this the courage it
takes to get up there in that room and
do that hit it chin to see the highs and
lows that's because of course they're
saying with in contact with Russia when
the Hillary campaign wasn't even in
contact with Michigan Democrats are
harder to make fun of because you guys
don't do anything
three moment you might flip the House
and Senate this November but you guys
always find a way to mess it up you're
somehow gonna lose by 12 points to a guy
named Jeff pedophile Nazi doctor I'm
telling me and she killed it's funny
stuff you own people get upset doctor
they get their feelings hurt cuz they're
so fun situation so again it's it's team
so people go on the property no attack
two different way to look at it that she
has nothing to do with politics she's
just she's there to roast people so what
she did was creative and fun she's not
anti what she's not trying to [ __ ]
everything right she's gonna make people
I wrench I thought it was good it's a
real comic to all the show up is a
monster I'm a little watch her new
special on HBO phenomenal I bet super
creative how well well I saw the part
where she did the Sarah Sanders thing
and well the surgeon I went I went it's
a little harsh but losses she's just
talking about her looks well she was
saying this is the day no she's got a
smoky eye which actually is a compliment
oh so maybe it's natural maybe in other
words you did a good job with your maker
you know what I like this cuz those
those White House elites no one talks
them like this and then you bring in a
eggless comic who's known for this ya
know who you're dealing they're also so
out of touch with America so you know
it's caught being inside the belt also
listen to that crowd she destroyed that
crowd but then the media goes she bombed
it was off no no no you said crowd
though you can tell people who are under
the [ __ ] teat of the government all
there's people like like dying light and
then there's the people in the back who
don't have anything do it our [ __ ]
howling howling I love that you said
just again any time you do a crowd like
that they're already very conservative
in explaining that be like yeah whatever
was hard is that yes I've done I've done
stand-up for pursuits people who are
corporate gig yeah there is this
especially inside the beltway Washington
is a very conservative place both
Democrats and Republicans very
conservative it's where innovation goes
to die they are not a loose-knit group
of people they are careful and it's all
what is it politics so you're careful
about what you laugh at you're careful
of what you say you have to read the
right things and it's called being
inside the beltway
and inside the beltway has they are not
in touch Democratic and Republican
especially Democratic strategists and
Hollywood and inside the beltway they're
not in touch with America no they don't
they just don't but I'll say this if I
was in Michelle was agent I would have
told her to do exactly this oh I would
know because she was an anti-trump she's
not anti-government she roasted
everybody in a crowd she sure did but
also I can see it's hidden have you
heard of Michelle wealth before this no
there wasn't you definitely do now and
I'm gonna watch her special you want
watch her special you know why cuz it's
brilliant you know it's brilliant and
she she actually her agents are jumping
up and down yes my sister-in-law her at
her business throw their company party
in Santa Barbara every year and they
brought her in to to talk and every year
they've had people just bomb bomb I told
him to bring you they've had people just
bomb like we don't know what to do
they've had ZZZ there and it just didn't
go well whatever they brought Michelle
wolf in and she brought the house down
you know how doing this exact same thing
yeah she literally went to the boss and
just started roasting him then his
friends and then what's going you
definitely miss she's dressed like that
and just started [ __ ] going hard at
everyone and he took it personal no by
the way you and I know that now if you
want to hire Michelle wolf and people do
for your for your your corporate gig you
can start you can start at 200 grand
oh yeah cuz that's what it's gonna cost
you and she's gonna get it 100% she's
gonna get it she's got right now her
agent is calling booked I don't your
book to 2020 like I don't know what to
do with I don't know your book Toussaint
went oh no oh yeah Netflix you know we
had that HBO deal now Netflix wants off
your colleges everybody wants Michelle
wolf because again she didn't Joe ball
she didn't go like that's that's what
that's what's inspiring to me too for
her to write this stuff get up in that
room I get nervous and thinking about it
me too when Jay goes have you
I'm like oh my god and I watch it and I
was [ __ ] howling in my house laughing
cuz I look at I go oh my god the courage
it took in the creativity and to
actually hit it out the park is insane
you know how like when Oprah I think was
the Golden Globes is gonna make the
speech on the me to movement and there's
so much pressure on her and I thought
good luck brother
and I even looked at I was doing the
preacher on post-show Frey looked at
everyone and I went listen yes have too
much expectations there's no way she can
lift all the expectations and she gets
up there and [ __ ] grant slams it out
of the park and you go yeah everyone had
goose bumps
standing ovations you're like oh my god
that's the to me that's like it's
alright no she's doing the
Correspondents Dinner like oh good luck
with that that's what started the whole
Trump thing right he got roasted at the
Correspondents Dinner right Mary got
roasted you'll never be president he
goes okay check and then runs for
president
yep so she does it and just [ __ ] no
[ __ ] and again it's different because
she didn't go to Amy Schumer the anti
you know Donald Trump thing that there's
a big difference here then she shouldn't
get hate from the Trump supporters they
brought her in remember they hired her
for this
so people are conflicting that with anti
Trump no no she's doing a job and did a
got it she's a coming a real comic no
and you're gonna be a real comic and
she's gonna she's gonna batter you
around a little bit yeah it's so funny
cuz she owes cuz she starts and she's
full of jabbing skills should have done
your research you don't know he brought
in here
it was I was like oh my god I thought
some I can't wait to watch it I can't
wait to watch long it's fantastic I love
that man I watch every minute of it
guts I want to do actually courage is an
interesting thing I wanted to play you
guys something you know my boyfriend
Frank Martin who's as it has
glioblastoma he has a bone brain yeah
yeah now he's got the worst brain tumor
the worst ones any good ones right now
but this one is this one's the monster
of all brain tumors stage for the second
yeah and a second craniotomy but the guy
has never lost his sense of humor ever
and I just I just quickly wanted to take
a little of your time to play you a
message he left me that [ __ ] crack me
up not long did they give him to live
well you know when you get a
glioblastoma you're given between 11
months and 15 months and this is these
are his spirits right now this is what a
man does please have please listen hold
please don't hit play for us though yeah
I'm hitting play sometimes it takes for
Lois it's a long way I don't know why
the voice that loads up but yeah I mean
his phone he's [ __ ] up against it
facing it and never loses his sense of
humor like just talks to me and we laugh
and be really good at this did fight
what the [ __ ] we [ __ ] come see your
boy again
dude I don't [ __ ] bring you up on
charges don't think I won't abandonment
to your Bubba all right and don't think
we don't have a real army and I don't
care about your MMA guys or frank grillo
especially I don't care about him and I
got some guys so you know that so we're
a little sick and tired of you coming
and doing a comedy night for me helping
me out making me love you even more than
I do
drawing me into your web of love when
you only have give it because you're
saving it for all these fans of yours I
wanted to say I watched your there was a
commercial on the other night for your
next show and I've been bragging about
you and saying how you stuck it out and
how they people don't people think these
people just get it all
right now the [ __ ] clubs you played
and Bobo you are doing it Bubba I am
glad and keep rising and keep going and
don't worry about little folks like me
or in the hospital for weeks at a time
barely able to walk you stays focus on
your careers
don't worry about people like me there
in the hospital dying don't worry about
it just every now and then pop and call
us act like you love us but don't worry
about us you just stay focused on your
career now seriously Bubba I'm so proud
of you and when you get a chance to call
me cuz I miss you and I'm proud of [ __ ]
of you
I got your own show Bubba that's sick
you stay with it and you made it and
that's it it's my call for the day what
the [ __ ] you got that's my boy that's my
[ __ ] boy who's a good girl seeing but
here's the thing no I will I'm gonna see
him and I'll be in New York 14 15 16 17
you see we're doing ourselves a podcast
from New York that's what I believe yeah
maybe we're gonna try and then and then
I'll be back there 24th I'll be fine
sube up figure out dude how about the
guest the year belt health legit are
those those are pretty bad hey Silvana
come pick up against the Year bill Wow
Michael rap boards not gonna be happy
dude this is all I've ever wanted to
first load logos from the day one logo
to the find the kid looks is amazing
please
what company made these Japanese muted
belts 83 and 67 hey I need
can we please can we get a couple
sweatshirts and t-shirts with never run
the Kennish I'd like to do a run of the
a bikini that was original and this one
I love this one you know what I mean I'd
love to do that the one the one loves
shirt sold out I love those one love
shirts
there's everybody's been hitting me up
with one love like when I take pictures
they're all like one they're all right
hey let me take a picture with the gay
owl or one love but that was a special
one love but whatever oh I know that
right there is great in that belt sweet
yeah one steal Vaughn toying with the
ideas
Thanks
- Stevie blue-eyes gaming day that gave
me the name batteries included for the I
feel like someone special not that madam
you see the specialist called batteries
included really it's a movie from the
batteries not included that is not yeah
batteries included when it batteries not
included
let me see it's not included there's no
batteries included good nope
nice okay kind of like that that's good
yeah I think you're safe batteries
batteries not included so on on the
right mm-hmm
and people have been giving me great
ideas thank you for everybody for
hitting me up with your ideas for my
special batteries included is a oh it's
a movie from 1988 yeah there's no
pictures on it yeah but there's no
commie social so it's perfect the book
I'm not mad at you dude you stole it
yeah all right we'll get things going
you're not mad at that
Talia hall I'm sorry tickets just went
on sale actually for Talia Hall Brendan
Schaub from the fighter and kid will be
opening for me okay except for the phone
I guess yeah yeah yeah and another show
and and the other show and I'm grateful
and is it called ungrateful is it called
stab you in the back is that what the
show's called I don't know your own show
it doesn't matter I don't give a [ __ ]
about me but from fighting a kid and the
other show I'm grateful and I don't give
a [ __ ] about you and that I'm out of the
nest
who are you I'm a italia hall tickets
are on sale I'll have a link for you you
[ __ ]
that's July win July 20th there's my
calendar always gonna be fun so we're
gonna do we're gonna have a whole thing
be fun yeah it's good let's make it a
weekend man I'm just shooting it right
so I'm just do my quick hour you do a
quick hour you just don't get off
brennon cut off I have my team they're
shooting that's my specialty
dammit that would be fun to do it no has
anyone ever done that a double feature
special yeah well they my first special
I ever shot man class they had like all
of us lined up it was like that's week
you want talking about a special event
you and me down the relative fun it'd be
fun got to do that we should be doing
the road you just be called to firing
the kid yeah
we had a good time Stevie and I had a
great time in Denver but it would have
been nice if you would come out I know I
should have came out cuz baby mom was
gone baby was at his grandma's I knew
that you I get I get weird by much you
were about yourself cuz I was like you
are unusually active on on my texting
and I was like yeah hey man what's going
on over there
how's Denver is the sun shining there's
a coffee shop I'm just walking I was
like hey man this guy hung out a lot it
is not like him
and then I remembered I'm like oh his
whole family's out of town that's right
just chill it's weird you like cuz I
don't get a lot of free time like that
so you don't really cause when I'm on
the road Jays with me or you know I'm
busy or you have shows here ready for I
don't really have a lot of downtime like
that's all I woke up why I still wake up
early as I try to recruit you to my to
my early dinner cuz my wife was like
we'll have an early dinner go all right
she goes 5:30 I was like what you guys I
sleep now she read that book why we
sleep which is that that guy Mark Walker
was on Malachor or whatever so um like
yeah last night I'm like doing my [ __ ]
it's like 10:30 I'm just I don't know
I'm like [ __ ] in the bathroom and I
just hear Brian I was he Shh be quiet
I'm trying to sleep I'm like I'm not
doing you're moving around I'm like whoa
it's Haley [ __ ] 10:30 sleeping now
yeah she's like she meditates she's got
to hear her sound machine I'm like with
his office he sleeps in porn Bob got
this man you should be you should be
clawing for my god corrects whispering
come home open our eyes wide open mess
yeah you should be asking me to gift you
my [ __ ] the baby bird um when you
touched me I was watching American Idol
the transgender man got or when we got
voted off damn man out racist man when
they did the voting called it that in
you when I don't reckon I can
unfortunate that stuff still exists when
I watch American Idol there in you and
the judge can't save them anymore so
only seven out of the ten went on either
eleven they do top 11 top seven so four
went home you best believe all the white
kids made it they did
mmm the white oh definitely don't I want
black you didn't make it by far the best
performer
to the night now wet clothes but the bib
but it's a mostly a white populace do
you think that played a factor it's the
only factor matter of fact I don't think
they should have leave it up to fan
voting I think the experts should decide
who gets a music contract really not the
people because if that's hot right okay
I guess that's part of the gig but let
them vote and then it should be 50/50
and then the judges can someone's and
they're gonna ultimately buy Mars a
Brian because name the name out of all
the American Idol winners name who's
killing it besides very few hi Clark's
Carrie Underwood Kelly Clark Clarkson
who else name the other ones that all
these moons people voted for weird why
doesn't that translate into ticket sales
concert sales album sales iTunes sales
why is that because they're not voting
the best people through everybody the
most popular yes the wrong people here's
a funny story I'm like them and then the
show's over and then they have to come
out with real music that they're not
seeing covers of and people go you're
not very good and the experts go no [ __ ]
but you guys asked for it and then
you're Ruben Studdard you're 600 pounds
open up a barbecue restaurant you know
cuz Clay Aiken run for governor with a
gut oh boy here's a got used to have a
show on I forget what is yeah let me
bring that bring up clay because III
Megan's voice in here when you're a
runner-up right here the third place
that I was doing karaoke in Florida and
one of the guys was there and I was like
oh well he looks like he's a like he
prosthetics like a prosthetic feels like
he had some cheek fillers yes he looks
like Kylie Jenner a lot of people get
fillers by the way there was a very very
day he's uh he's not been missing any
meal
so I'll suck your dick raw gay he's very
gay whatever that means right that's
right I heard well usually sucking a
dick raw would be well you don't know
might do some strange for a little bit
of change
doctor chrome off a trailer hitch um
it's like the leather off a fight blow
he he has a how old is he now no no he
ran for governor and I don't think it
worked out is he hang like a bat is he a
vampire
yeah now is he starring the neck in the
newest Twilight or he always just clear
like that 39 I'm
is that old 39 that make sense no yeah
super fat well he hold I think that
maybe happy with it yeah oh no it Tina's
got no brain okay I do think that when
people what I notice is as old men get
older people get older if they're not
careful of how they eat if they eat a
lot of carbs and my Saudis they get they
get bloated their face get oh yeah I can
you know why even me I'll wife I'll work
out like crazy like yesterday was my
cheat meal day
so I eleven hundred calories on the
peloton and then my dinner was ice cream
yeah I like to do that on Sundays they
go east to west but but your face will
blow up from all the sugar yeah sugar
sugar and sodium he's a guy he's a man
who doesn't grow all that hair on his
face that's a that's a tough one for
some people cuz you you know it's a
tough looking older face but then your
gut still baby skin look like but it but
again you know like an older B America
Vote so these people and they wonder
where they're at like well you did
invoke the best ones through because you
for a reason they remind you of
themselves or they remind you of
something and did he winter took second
place he's got second to Ruben Studdard
Ruben in him were who's Ruben Studdard
exactly Brian that's the [ __ ] problem
with the show you know else's problem
with the show it's all three it's all
three Lee guests or all three of the
judges are so goddamn nice there's no
real criticism there's zero criticism
you're the best
it's all gonna work out you're gonna be
a star hate to tell you no you're not
you know so if you aren't well what
about the voice do those guys go on to
do great sort of I think one wasn't that
one guy we let's do that Colin whatever
Javier remember that guy really hard
he's great right sold seven albums yeah
tough one powerful well backstreet's
back alright guess my kids are not gonna
take singing lessons or at least not end
up on there yeah look at all the winners
no one's doing [ __ ] sorry here Fred oh
did you buy that new CD from Danielle
Bradbery oh no you didn't swear
Frederick's make it he's got a cool hat
oh do you hear the new single that hot
single from Jordan Smith no
how about Cassidy it's all honey [ __ ]
people Pope Messi sounds like familiar
and never heard of her and they all have
pipes they can all say offense ain't
saying but you gotta have the complete
kind of package don't you don't you have
to be out writing your own music don't
you have to be the guy who writes more
like really means written for stuff like
that I got a you but she's also Rihanna
she's also drip drip she's also
astonishing and and so is um Sandra Day
like when you listen to her saying I the
light that never fades Sandra Brown the
light there and fill like she said just
see Sandra Day Android a Android a boy
no a girl she was the one who sang
Sandra and Roberta day she's the one
she's she's a killer
like you don't get although she's
amazing she can sing oh my tribe you let
sing in the world perhaps perhaps yeah
yeah yeah she's right there she's right
there mommy's our driver
she's there's something sexy about you
goddang right there me thank God LF she
is right there
I love her I'll make out with let's girl
me her go get a meal together take it
easy bro damn easy bro leave me bro just
do it just like two-for-one at Chili's
yeah she can Gian scene say it's crazy
she's so talented light that never fade
all right yet some kerlix Jenny yeah
first one is that well this is Dana
White's Instagram but this guy James
Shaw the Waffle House hero who disarmed
that gunman do you guys know I'm talking
about I now know for sure okay yes
because we pay attention gingers [ __ ]
know what happened at Waffle House oh no
no no so this guy this guy's in the hero
so he disarmed that gunman and then
threw the gun over the counter and the
guy took off whatever there so this guy
people actually what Brian who's that
guy did it you don't know no no no I
didn't say he definitely died said he
disarmed him yeah yeah
him and his buddy actually were helping
victims out keep going Jim so he he
started in a GoFundMe account to raise
money for the shooting victims and then
he's donating all that stuff to
obviously their funeral expenses
everything else and he only wanted to
raise like fifteen thousand in the
beginning but it turned up to like more
than a hundred sixty-five thousand
dollars let him keep something he's
giving it all away to the families god
bless you did what a great person
yeah great he's honest too he said like
I did that because I try to save my own
life all right
yeah but thank God has saved other
people man but that's why Dana no date
without that yeah we got for our milk
give him a dog give him money right now
you know I love that I don't ask for
much man
yeah give her a million I love that guy
by his house that's all by my house
that's all I would be in Florida it's
nothing much thing I have a $200,000
house please we'll buy him a $500,000
house and then give him a mil in the
bank that's all that's nothing i standed
I if I had four hundred million dollars
I swear to god I'd do that but I would
do I really would I want to be that rich
and I would just be like James now I'm
after you guys
now listen James not when I'm
informative uses a [ __ ] pad so you have
to get rid of your kid that's quick yeah
okay now this is gonna sting a little
bit I know don't listen now listen I
know it's Christmas but they know you
know the rules bro I'm Horning no you
have your family out cuz up a couple
hole you're gonna get your family out
cuz I gotta get this dick out
yeah he's family out cuz I'm dropping
some good yeah I'm gonna get this deck
on Christmas Day just some Miami
Brazilian I need you to get to all that
closed-circuit TV boarded up as well
can't have any no you can stay but you
have to get the wife and kids out nasty
an ass I got a hazmat team and also I
need to get down all the family pigs cuz
that that's a bump the family kids the
family picks that's a boner kill so go
ahead and take those down some out there
I mean I've been I've been I've been you
know gifting gifting my wife with my
essence and I'll hear instance upstairs
and I'm like that's my daughter and I
don't have a lock on my office and I'm
like well I just lost my face in the
middle of the day no
oh and I keep getting scared or
something I married fish no such thing
as that um yeah no it's and I'm like I'm
like oh and then I just I can't no game
over kids involved can't do it it's a
lot of information and I'm bored with
all right keep moving
shut up to James Shaw Dana White stop
right give a million buy my house
toss them fair enough balls it as a [ __ ]
bet as you already know Bill Cosby's
guilty on all three counts you see him
talking [ __ ] everyone you know like
scare people know we start talking [ __ ]
it's pretty it's pretty funny well
because they go don't we don't want to
post bail cuz he has a private airplane
we mean inside the court playing you
[ __ ]
you just started you know he's awfully
going away for a very long yeah he's
awfully gonna die in the next year so
what happens is when you look like a
burnt turtle out of it's shell and
you've had a rough go and you get to
prison you die you know I'm saying what
a fall from grace oh my god your whole
life granted phd's and honorary PhD
Hughes the father of the nation for a
while right yeah he was dead were you
laugh at the Berto pretty funny it's got
two lovely daughters son was killed
well the great I'm not I'm not
advocating for what the man did I'm
saying as a comedian he's one of the
greatest of all time yes he is yeah
that's not even that question yes he
made jello University Cosby's honorary
Regents
Oh everything oh no everything you work
for the skills yeah you can't rape
hundreds of girls and just be cool
no you can't you can't athlete I mean
just like a cheap [ __ ] on the highest
level but he never really got his as far
as this isn't sufficient discipline cuz
how old is he 18
I think it's 84 okay all right he's 80
right he basically lived his entire life
money fame mansion
rating hundreds of women slept with
millions of hundreds of women he's made
he's done his brown
he's done his go yeah and then I eighty
get caught I know but I I just like this
is [ __ ] I think life when he's happens
when you're Kim you thought about your
legacy right and that's gone I mean but
also how your family looks at you your
children I mean I I just like but we'd
only get written I'm not comparing the
two I'm saying Richard Pryor had you
know he used to beat his wife well
Richard Pryor that was more than a case
personally destructive like Richard
Pryor was but he's a woman being Israel
that's well documented yeah yeah I don't
know so but it's back to the day but the
time has passed we're now we don't and
you don't think about we think was just
this is different isn't it it's
different huh this is oh you don't say
no systematic and and over 30 years of
drugging women and oh it's some dark
[ __ ] I mean I gotta be honest the Bill
Cosby movie is gonna be a heater crazy
movie I don't we give me on lifetime cuz
I don't want to see the movie I know I
need some real effort put in this movie
yeah the scripts are out I guarantee it
you think so
hundred-percent he made a Charles Manson
movie yeah Wow they made a joke Paterno
movie he's going to jail Sandusky raping
a little kids yeah well they're gonna
appeal it but I don't matter man no I
don't
he's just delaying that he's gonna die
oh wise we found him just mysteriously
dead at the house he's probably and take
that Mike I would do that Oh after 84 go
to prison
or what if he is no I would say listen
I'd call my doctor Mike that Armand
Reich's house long as I can the day I'm
supposed to go have someone come in here
leave me the needle I'm gonna put in my
name and go out I'm here's the will it's
pretty swell I'm not dying in those
prison cells yes it he could go to jail
though and you know knowing him he
probably beat like hold classes and [ __ ]
yeah I could totally imagine him being
like the the fathers he'll be there they
said OJ Simpson was a model prisoner
held classes got religious I have no
doubt no doubt
taking classes and crime thing is that
you are some people have like the
outside of their personality but they're
not all bad like only is a sickness most
of us not with dudes yeah here's a
sickness it now
if there's women around I don't know you
don't want Bilka I had 84 though but
still you don't want to run around dudes
oh the dudes he like well yeah but when
it comes to rape guys really don't [ __ ]
with that there was a guy's get [ __ ]
up in prison when they have rape
yeah but he's such a huge celebrity I
think people in jail they're probably
like oh my crap that's that's Bill Cosby
and they wanted to say like crab see oh
my god yeah oh my crap no I think you're
right I think at 80 he would get a pass
you guys are nothing we like I don't
like him but if I was in prison and he
wanted to befriend me I got to be honest
I'd probably like oh crap it's Bill
Cosby yeah I don't like what you did but
it's Bill Cosby yeah and also yeah I
don't know I don't know we're gonna be
very interesting to see
they'll be tough Oh Bill Cosby the
rather Mendez brothers when they
murdered their parents they're in the
cell and xlj Simpson and they said they
just talked to OJ anything cool huh he
was going through his trolleys with the
Mendez brothers
what gym Kanye's next album it's called
Trump no it's he's actually considering
putting on the face of the doctor that
killed his mom accidentally killed his
mom the plastic surgeon yeah because he
wants to forgive he wants to just love
now he's mother so she so his mother
wanted all the splash surgery done at
the same time just knocking on one shot
and then went to a few doctors I went
too dangerous yeah chance for making it
through so not good
then I found this doctor oh I can do it
and she died well he was ambitious and
tried well right yeah but as a medical
professional I can't risk that
yeah there's a reason why the top doctor
says his license no he's in jail I think
right yeah he's not doing good
really yeah John Adams surgeon in
Chicago Oh God
some dark [ __ ] uh yeah what was this
surgery she was getting like baby-faced
stuff and best
five things about pi surgeon on Connie's
mom for the deathless Jan Adams just
growing down does it just go one two he
Harvard University in Ohio State before
he studied plastic we just shiny
yep he's gained national exposure after
appearing on several poplar talk shows
all right the death of Don de Kanye's
mom he spoke out to defend himself from
the accusations that her demise is due
to his wrongdoing
John 15 every call out Kanye and blame
Kanye's cousin Steven Scoggins who was
taking care of Donda after a final
surgery for her death Wow
gentlemen the two malpractice lawsuits
against him ended in payouts and before
and after the infamous surgery he had
multiple DUI offenses okay we had some
issues hmm so arrested for DUI driving
without a license 2008 sentenced to one
year in jail a 2009 and then surrendered
his license in 2009 she they think she
died and on table didn't even know this
lady was home for a day
oh through hasn't been revealed she
aspirated the food contents in their
lungs and that's match so she choked
okay so she choked she said that so
Jimmy Hendrix died
it ain't magical the coroner an autopsy
on donned terrible name concluded that
he couldn't determine what exactly
caused her death but confirmed that the
vomiting and medications for the pain
were contributing factor oh my gosh she
might have she might have shown oh well
the coroner couldn't determine right so
maybe she she choked yeah maybe but he's
I pass on him doing any surgery though
well you know I'll see you want to be
fair you know I don't know I want to see
the I'm sure there's a bunch that went
into it but so yes for but this might be
common with their with their in their
field we get sued because he has his two
or three major malpractice and
malpractice major especially well they
add DUI that's whatever people like to
party what else yet all right you guys
kinda already talked about the Korean
thing but it is a pretty huge deal
you are seven decades the biggest deal
in my people's lives for us like
especially this decisions
China doesn't unify what's your family
say about a chin there in the beginning
they were so skeptical like they wanted
yeah they're so skeptical skeptical but
after watching this stuff they're kind
of like they're kind of changing their
minds a little bit because he's
admitting a lot of things like his
wrongdoings like they're nowhere near
America or South Korea or any other
country like they're struggling he's
admitting this so that just tells you
like normally they would you never want
to say that South Korea which is he said
his frickin airplane is not good enough
to fly far so if when he meets Trump he
wants to meet in a certain area that
that could here they just don't have
modern technology like when he was a
China I think it's [ __ ] crazy
this is this is his historic level these
hand we may see Christine realization of
the Korean Peninsula and you got a thank
Ron you've got to thank him for it
seriously you Trump fair now chin do you
think more Korean Americans be Trump I
guarantee I'm pretty sure right they
can't ignore this you can't ignore the
way North Korea treated South Korean it
was literally overnight it was like
happens he's gonna get reelected and I
might even go so far say [ __ ] if you
vote for me I I'm I will say this I have
make it easy [ __ ] I have grudging take
it easy foxy admiration for what he's
been able to accomplish that's what is
impressive I don't I still stand by it I
don't like him as I think he's a
narcissist chin come true we walk in
here with make America great again no
I'm afraid my way smarter than I thought
I'm not gonna I'm gonna give it some
time I like lemon little Wally's blame
you pick a fight with this guy and
geopolitics when it comes to geopolitics
being a nice guys [ __ ] what we know
from history is that as a country's
respect strength yeah Russia and
everybody be as nice as you want buddy
buddies go on hunting trips whatever you
want with Putin what Putin or people in
power understand his power mm-hmm
and so he's willing to use it here a big
stick Todd loveseat they are afraid that
he might be doing this to do something
bad later they just gained everyone's
trust but at the same time at the hip
lies
like it's all good yep yeah I'm softly
its carry a big stick
isn't that Teddy Roosevelt is that right
walk softly and carry a big stick a look
at that up
but Trump walks loudly and carries a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh speaking of big sticks
who's that Rico the guy who's the porno
started obsessed with ready yeah a
little thing that the fans kept sending
me you know you're just gay porn so you
know he's a gay man so when you when you
saved your favorite fans you know it
makes sense because no I say this he's
your favorite he's my favorite stupid
big deal I know I know yeah I got it all
the time relax you son of a [ __ ] you're
a click on images oh my god hold on yeah
there is that Photoshop know it or not
that's him sucking now Brian Photoshop
that's him suck yeah that's all
Photoshop bro now click on porn on now
hey video all you guys are idiots rocco
siffredi doesn't duplicate does Brian
I've seen it with my own eyes you've
never gone to poorab Wow guys suck on
the other ones boss click aah
so weird right what is Peters not
destroyed I promise you no I promise you
if you if your computer gets destroyed I
will buy a new one this click on pornhub
$3,700 cool I will buy your new one
god dammit what are you worried about
it's gonna get infected right there Rock
go see a huge clock where where Round
Rock go Colby - does that do it how
about rock so we prove this not know we
have it yeah that's him at the far right
Freddy's never done a gay porn yeah
that's not rock oh man don't say this is
your favorite Rocky's never done off the
screen right now just wanna see Gabe are
no your boy you're a huge fan of a game
points never done a galaxy I don't care
you're a 50-ohm an injustice closet I
want support you guys don't know what
you're doing are you I want you all to
take it back and tell Brendan you're
lying
don't think somewhat will of course if I
just looked at it
Rocco's not in those iron like him he
may produce but he's not produced nuts
in their mouth I ever got Sid Rico ah no
he [ __ ] rock on now Rico so you
obviously have no clubs he doesn't get
fun let's see it with my own eyes he's
never [ __ ] a guy it's not boss you
wanna bet
yeah how much I just looked at it I
promise you he's [ __ ] dudes there's no
way I promise you know I would have I
would know and they would have sent it
listen you're 51 you're the big day out
there's nothing wrong with this when I
saw it all that makes sense
no it's not true and I really am pissed
now that you even talk about my [ __ ]
hero like that what do I have heroes and
I'm standing on the shoulders of giants
and a giant let's try your stay on the
shoulders gay giant sucking dick Allen
no what you're doing is you're playing
chicken with gays you stand on men's
shoulders it's called chicken in the
pool but you're getting dicks in your
mouth and there's nothing wrong with
that zero rocker I'm looking at it right
now
yes oh you wanna do you poor yeah this
is not Rocco guys got a [ __ ] hammer
on them so who's that guy Oh God maybe
Chan what else you got
it's cut to me just keep looking oh yeah
there's that out there out there let me
let me immediately erase this let me
know like if you go to my wife about
what do you love to yell it shows me I
keep losing my voice I keep losing my
voice drop I'm literally I'm gonna punch
you in the [ __ ] reel or go suck dick
in my ass do this can you do this we're
not doing this where's the ladies chin
what do you got as a photograph that's
someone captured which is I guess one in
a trillion or one in a million of an
osprey carrying a shark but check out
can you tell what's going on here hi
it's one in a trillion I want to show
you see the shark is cute in its claws
right so look what it is in the shark's
mouth well fish so the bird caught a
shark that was eating a fish and it's
the shark is that it looks like a baby
two for one yeah it's a baby shark yeah
that's pretty cool though now be sweet
if there's like a big-ass great white
let the big-ass bird he does shark enjoy
that tough [ __ ] skin and walked right
out of the [ __ ] you see dark yeah
sure virtually the [ __ ] out of you burn
also eat other birds in Tibet they date
they put your body out that crack your
skull and the birds take all of you oh
well you know that right you know what
it's about in Burroughs you've seen it
Tibetan burial no chin google tibetan
bird burial yeah do not see that where
the weather no is it like is it like a
pat rite of passage crackers rose up it
is on the birds the birds come down and
eat you oh my god that's when you pass
away do me a favor uncut wouldn't pass
away kill you go you go away it's called
that they do that no extra I'm not mad
at that couldn't be is it hey you tell
me what what's difference between that
and then cremation when you [ __ ] put
your body and by flames I really get
eaten cool by birds and take a bunch of
pics at me to I'll be stung that ass
I'll be honest and just a dozen soldiers
pick you clean that's always been the
case though back in the day they're
vultures on a station they'll call this
bed and Book of the Dead which I've read
oh my gosh that's to go back go back
don't worry don't worry I'll look at it
yeah that's
they dress the bodies they dress the
bodies for the bird keep going chin
can't stand that stuff when Tibet
islands but what's wrong with that chin
if what's the demonstrating that and
then bearing so Nate great eight feet
under is that more human dude bodies are
dead these pictures are crazy though
really just scroll down but don't click
on it to say but this one right here it
looks crazy they dress the body for the
you know they basically make it easier
with the vultures like it like dumped
like seasoning all over it
Italian dress no but they they Paul they
put like Lowry seasoning salt no sir I'm
going to ask you to be quiet now they
baby Paul they doused the head in a once
I know it's part of being close to the
idea of the line between life and death
and and Antony conquering your fear of
death it's all part of it makes you more
scared of death that I know I'm gonna be
devoured by birds when I pass away large
birds toss me in with a Gators baby
right will you do that for me I'm not
tossing you the Gators but I'm taking it
to bet to a flight and know my body had
died by then crackers got my mind up my
body will just be like mush after that
you sent me to Florida and then you find
those Gators out I know because the
Gators annoy me and I don't want it's
just so impersonal by all the way eat
they're just like yeah yeah what was it
was it was it oh yeah Knicks worse than
talking about that [ __ ] that Gator say
yeah angels were like okay thanks Angela
really
hi what else yet ten boy how about how
random is finding the kid we watched gay
porn and vultures eating dead human
which is what we don't watch know what
to Trump yeah we've cover your cover in
the world
dude that's what we find a name my
podcast Brian's world Brian's world
Brian's world might be good right it's
Brian's world can do Brian town's world
doesn't flow okay guys world like
Bobby's world Brian five guest brides
well not Brian Cowen
no okay Brian's world yeah the house let
it flows we all know Bryan Callen guys
world for your special no oh I'm gonna
do my podcast I'm renaming it from arts
to Brian's world has so many fun guests
on that I want people to hear it's like
an hour and I
talk to fun smart people Brian's world
right sure world yeah Brian's world
that's good and I like American boy
American Motors tool is so amazing if
you did that so funny but I'm freaking
wasn't 51 his culture
you can't know American boner if that
popped up on screen like on Netflix you
would immediately like what the [ __ ] is
this
you'd 100 you're right yeah or Hulu yeah
anything people would be more drawn to
it if it's called American butter you
get more eyeballs but I just can't be
that much of an idiot I'm an idiot
I know that was great yeah I'm an
American boner cuz you know in another
word for boner is right mmm accident I
pulled a real boner which is an accident
well there you go
I'm such a bonehead American accident
that's not bad
American accidents fun how do you think
lose almost too on the nose
I like the awkward truth oh no no no
sounds like you're linking up with
[ __ ] they doing conspiracy theories
yeah but American accidents actually
really good American accents for yeah I
like American something mr. Boehner's
gonna write number one in my book this
is the first thing I've ever heard you
know why because you're cute like if
your date if I'm not gonna say a comma
quit if you're like kind of a gimmicky
comic and call american boner and people
watching like Jesus Christ man but with
you you know it's it's legit humor it's
like real cerebral stuff yeah so that's
why it works yeah yeah just you know
what sit on it
I've been sitting I haven't sitting sit
on that and big American boner
God has hit funny should we have the
fans vote on it I feel like we should do
a [ __ ] so we have the fatties
included American Bowl and American
boner American accident and I'll come up
some other things we can't have too many
threes I'm good I like that
American boner would be a fine t-shirt
just what does it work though because it
has to be associated with something yeah
so we can't just make sure to say you
know you could make jiggy we should make
underwear
we should make underwear we should team
up with me undies and just haven't been
the American boner series God we may not
I can't but I like this you don't have
the balls dude it's funny though that
what you like groundbreaking like no one
has ever done that crazy of a think so
mate blow up it blows up yeah that's our
fan base for sure I guarantee you
everyone right now if you went batteries
included American boner or what was the
other one American Psycho American
accent American Psycho two American
accident I guarantee by a landslide
American bonus number one yeah probably
but you're thinking about everything
right politics and all that stuff oh
yeah but it's just it's so funny it's so
that when I thought of it I started
laughing so me too my only caveat with
that and we can talk to him so I wonder
if if you're gonna go on Showtime or
Netflix update there's people with way
worse names than that I've seen some
specials where I'll Netflix would have
no problem show times I have no problem
at American boner so stupid it's not a
bad word out it's not a bad word should
we put the voting on TV okay
yeah j-bird get the voting t5k American
boner American accident batteries
included once you say the other ones it
does you know there's no hype on how
about boners including how about this
boner included Bryan Callen included
fine towns call me stretch chill boners
included just boner down get your boner
batteries and boner included that's
actually funny get your Ryan Kalin
batteries and barn food
you could just really be an [ __ ] and
just go you just do bright yeah I have a
boner boner so funny I have about this
boner bride down you see Browns news
comedy special what is it boner
[Laughter]
dude it's really everything boner
have you seen news special what's the
guy's name I don't know it's called
boner it's [ __ ] great I think
American bars make it vulnerable at all
it's the greatest thing of all time I
might call it that the shirts we could
make off American boner the American Bar
and and the poster I can see down better
you hear those two words on Rudy words
American poner so like Putin and it's
like really but that's up to me I like
it cuz we're do you call you know what
any call it you know those everyone does
the right thing I like the curve balls
in because you're not a gimmick comic
it's worked so good I'm not Gallagher no
I'm not this is the best thing I've ever
written in time it's so powerful an
American boner it's [ __ ] good man I
like it for marketing reasons yeah okay
sit on it though I'm less a sealant so
honest American bullet in my ass as we
speak I'm thinking about it it's crazy
let's have the Fayetteville so maybe
sway even more but I like American boner
I love the other ones like we were
eating gone through I'm like yeah of
course and you know I was thinking I'm
like I've seen that that's cool it's not
gonna stick out and well I'm scrolling
and it says their components click and
then they watch my school she's [ __ ]
hilarious Hosie he's 51 oh my god it's
the best thing ever that is community
ball time it is the best thing I've ever
done I think is I'm I'm the happiest
I've ever been on my stand
oh yeah I had got the mission boner that
I have to save Denver's maybe the best
shows of my life I was the best shows
all right [ __ ] that's funny
American butter makes me laugh let's
wrap it up we'll just get you that's it
we'll get your American boners out hey
soda come see me in Colusa casino this
Saturday speaking of this
one show only Colusa casino I like
Colusa it's about an hour outside
Sacramento yeah it's nice yeah and then
this weekend I'm in Minnesota House of
Comedy Mall of America finally at
monarch I've always wanted to go there
I'll be eating Cinnabons shopping with
my shark eyes doll smile comedy at night
2 shows Friday to show Saturday all
shows are almost sold out get tickets
right now for Brian and myself tea fat
cake calm and then June I'm in Houston
end of June I'm in Houston get a snout f
@k and calm more date American cancel
what is it American boner I had to
cancel my San Diego dates Oh why I'm
doing this movie so I had to cancel San
Diego I'm sorry but I'll be back but I
will be when you're going to buy tickets
for Brendan I'll be at the house of
comedy at the end of May May 31st June
1st
just a second so come see me at the
house of comedy boom there you go
Minnesota step game up let's get weird
American boner this is a foreign kid
we're out